we begin with breaking news out of
Malaysia where the Prime Minister
Mahathir Mohamad has offered his
resignation to the king and his
political party has quit the ruling
Alliance now this decision shocked
Malaysia and it comes in in the midst of
plans by Maha tear supporters to team up
with opposition parties to thwart the
transition of power to his name
successor on Laura Ibrahim let's go live
to Florence lui
and Kuala Lumpur so Florence what have
you been able to learn is this
news has come out while we learnt that
Mahathir Mohamad submitted his letter of
resignation to the king of malaysia as
what 1:00 p.m. local time this afternoon
now it's not yet known whether the King
has accepted the resignation but
according to constitutional experts
because the Kings role is largely a
ceremonial role he will have to then
what happens next is also a little bit
unclear now the king has to appoint
someone who commands the majority or
confidence of Parliament so then it
becomes a numbers game but we also have
the information now that Mahathir party
has left the ruling coalition and the
rumors are that this party is going to
team up with other parties to form
another coalition so they could still
command the majority in parliament and
they could still very much be in power
none so that's the state of politics in
Malaysia a moment but the background
information of this as well is that you
know these this is something that
political watchers in Malaysia been
speculating about that there is a plan
to prevent an way bra him from becoming
the next prime minister now there was an
agreement between Mijares party and the
other parties in the then ruling
coalition that there would be a handover
of power within two years of the last
general election that maja they would
hand over power to Anwar Ibrahim now
that's supposed to happen sometime in
the next few months but Mohave has
delayed that saying that he's not going
to be ready to hand over power until
after the until after an important
asia-pacific meeting in November in
Kuala Lumpur and now we have that now
the speculation that he is doing this so
that Anwar doesn't become the next prime
because if he has enough numbers to form
a ruling coalition to be part of the
ruling coalition then our noit's party
and our newest supporters will won't
have a chance to form the next
government now but who are Mahathir is
coalition partners for the rumor to be
the former ruling party unknown now this
is the party that was defeated in the
last general election it's been leader
Najib Razak was accused of siphoning
billions of dollars from a state
investment fund and is currently on
trial for corruption
now this party could be coming back into
power but that is all just speculation
however lending support to this
speculation is the fact that members of
this party as well as members of Mijares
party held a meeting just yesterday on
Sunday held a meeting and they were
taught that there were rumors that these
the meeting is to well really to form
the next to form a coalition so they
have enough numbers to make sure they
have enough numbers to be the majority
in parliament Michelle all right
Florence Louie gathering were on this
breaking news that the Prime Minister of
Malaysia has submitted his resignation
we'll gather more Thank You Florence so
Bridgette your reaction to this
announcement well it's considerable a
lot of drama and Malaysia today and the
last weekend as well we've seen now the
resignation of my tier but he's supposed
to meet the king tonight so there's a
chance he might come back
so what really what do you think is at
play here why is this happening well I
think that they there was too much
tension inside the existing coalition
that had governed Malaysia since May
2018 there was challenges over reform
but particularly over with setting a
transition date for on rubra him and the
coalition basically collapsed and so we
now see a situation where things have
been very fluid in the last two days
particularly last night and then today
and we're seeing either a new coalition
forming a new or a new election what are
the real issues between on mari brahim
and and my magic hero Mohammed
principal they're actually - one has to
do with issues and perceptions of race
relations and the other has to do with
issues of patronage I think these things
are very much at the core there have
been differences over reform as well as
so what could add that to the mix but
generally a lot of these issues have
been percolating but a lot has to do all
with also with personality these two men
have a history a long history my dear
put on where Abraham in jail and and it
came together and now I think we're
seeing a situation where to monetary
Malaysia seems unwilling to let Anwar
take power again so anyways so far who
is going to benefit from this or is it
is it too soon as hell right now
well nobody's benefitting right now I
think the this is this political and
economics in insecurity is really
hurting the country because people are
all transfixed watching this so I think
until it unfolds we're not going to be
able to make a clear assessment of how
Malaysia is going to move forward all
right everybody it's highly fluid okay
and we will be calling on you again
Bridget Welsh the author of a regime
resilience in Malaysia thank you very
much most welcome